كيف قالت السلطات الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه تستهدفت للمدينه بسبع مسيرات من
نوع شاهد خلال ساعات الليل ماده الى اصابه
ثلاثه مدنيين على الاقل واشارت اداره
الطوارئ الاوكرانيه الى ان احدى المسيرات
استهدفت مؤسسه تعليميه في المدينه والحقت
اضرارا بها واستهدفت مسيره اخرى مجمعا
رياضيا
للمزيد تنضم الينا
دريدي ومن سلوفيانس مراسل الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم نرحب بكم ايدان ونبدا مع كيرانيا
دريدي عن هذه التطورات احباط لهجمات
طائرات مسيره في موسكو وايضا زوارق
مسيره ماذا بعد ذلك على المستوى الرسمي
الروسي
بدايه يعني ازدهار بالفعل هذا هو الهجوم
هو الهجوم الثالث في غضون اسبوع واحد بحسب
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه هذا الهجوم تم
تنفيذه باستخدام ثلاث مسيرات اوكرانيه
مسيرتين تم اسقاطهما في ضواحي العاصمه
موسكو بينما المسيره الثالثه تم اسقاطها
باسقاطها باستخدام وسائل الحرب
الالكترونيه وخلال سقوطها اصطدمت او
باحد ابراج الضخمه في منطقه موسكو سيتي
حيث نحن نتواجد الان واود الاشاره الى انه
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه المنطقه لا تزال
مطوقه هناك انتشار امني هناك يعني وجود لي
رجال الامن لرجال الاطفاء في المنطقه
فعليا بدات عمليات ازاله الدمار شيئا
فشيئا ولكن حركه المرور يعني لم يتم
ايقافها او تعليقها هذا المبنى الذي تم
اهدافه هو يعني هو ذاته ذات المبنى الذي
تم استهدافه قبل يعني يوم يوم قبل امس اي
قبل يومين هذا يعني البرج هو احد الابراج
الثلاثه عشر التي تقع في هذا المركز
التجاري الضخم
لنا هذا المبني يضم ممثليات عدد من
الوزارات الروسيه يضم يعني
مكاتب للشركات الحكوميه
للشركات النفط الروسيه والشركات الضخمه
بشكل عام يعني وفقا للتصريحات الرسميه
الروسيه هذا العمل او هذا الهجوم تضعه
موسكو في خانه الاعمال الارهابيه وكانت قد
حذرت السلطات الاوكرانيه مرارا لاسيما في
الاونه الاخيره من انها ستقوم بالرد
بصرامه والخارجيه الروسيه قالت انها يعني
ستبقي لنفسها الحق بالرد بصراحه على هذه
على مثل هذه الهجم
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن هدد باستهداف مناطق
اكثر حساسيه بالنسبه لكيف اشار الى ضروره
ان تقوم روسيا بالرد على مثل هذه الخطوات
عبر استهداف مراكز مهمه ليس فقط مستودعات
الوقود والذخائر والبنه التحتيه التابعه
للطاقه بشكل عام بالفعل خلال الاونه
الاخيره من الملحوظ ازدهار ان عدد الهجمات
على العاصمه موسكو ازداد ولكن ايضا لابد
من الاشاره الى ان الجانب الروسي على
الاقل خلال الهجمات التي تم تنفيذها خلال
هذا الاسبوع قد نجحت يعني اسقاط كل
المسيرات هذه المسيرات فعليا لم تصل الى
اهدافها وفقا للتصريحات الرسميه منها ما
يتم اسقاطه باستخدام انظمه الدفاع الجوي
يسقط حتى على مشارف العاصمه قبل وصولها
كما حدث اليوم كما حدث قبل يومين ولكن
بالفعل هناك لا عندما يتم اسقاط بعض
المسيرات باستخدام وسائل الحرب
الالكترونيه فهي تسقط بشكل عشوائي
وبالتالي تلحق اضرار حتى وان كانت يعني
طفيفه كما هو يعني المشهد اليوم هنا
ولكنها تلحق ادرار بمراكز قد تكون مهمه
وحيويه واود الاشاره الى ان هذا المعلم
هذا البرج الذي تم استهدافه اليوم هو يعني
يدخل في اطار منطقه موسكو التي تعد احد
المعالم الحديثه والمهمه بالنسبه لروسيا
المراكز التجاريه وبشكل عام بالفعل يعني
سقوطها وحتى ولو كان السقوط ليس يعني
مباشر ولكن هذا يعد ضربه معنويه لروسيا
كون هذه المسايات بغض النظر عن انها
استهدفت يعني ضربت اهدافها ام لا لكنها
طالت المناطق الحيويه طالت قلب العاصمه
موسكو تبقين معنا رانيا نذهب الى سوف من
هناك مازن ابراهيم ربما يوضح لنا ردود
الفعل الاوكرانيه على ما تقوله وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بانه كان هناك محاوله
للهجوم على اسطول البحر الاسود لكنها فشلت
وارى انك تقف في مكان ربما تعرض
للقصف كيف تصف الوضع
نعم في الواقع عبد السلام وازدهار القصف
يستمر بطبيعه الحال على كامل المنطقه
الشرقيه وهو لا يفرق بين مناطق قريبه من
الجبهه او بعيده عنها سواء هنا او في
غيرها من المناطق ما يمكن قولها حول طبيعه
المواجهه الدائره سواء في جنوب البلاد من
خلال محاوله الاستهداف الاوكراني للاسطول
اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي بالاضافه الى
ما يحصل على طول خط الجبهه من الواضح ان
القياده الاوكرانيه باتت تبحث وتسعى
لارساء تبادل في الردع توازن في الردع بين
الطرفين بمعنى ان هنالك معادله جديده تعمل
القياده الاوكرانيه على ارسائها من خلال
ارسال المسيرات من خلال استهداف الاسطول
الاسود اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي وايضا
ما بات يعرف بالعمليات الخاصه صحيح ان هذه
المعادله قد لا تكون على نفس القدر من
القدره القتاليه والفتاكه لارسال المسيرات
الى موسكو ولكن العمليه باتت واضحه
بالنسبه للقياده الاوكرانيه هي تسعى جهدها
كي تاسس لمفهوم جديد في هذا الصراع يقوم
على تبادل الردع بمعنى انه بالامس كان
هنالك استهداف في كليفري من خلال الصواريخ
قال بانها من نوع اسكندر صاروا اسكندر ادت
الى مقتل سته اشخاص واصابه اكثر من 70
بجراح كذلك تم استهداف وغيرها من المناطق
تذهب الى المسيرات الى عمق موسكو صحيح بان
هذا البعد لارسال المسيرات هو بعد رمزي
معنوي ولكن من خلاله تحاول ارسال اكياب
هذه المعادله بطبيعه الحال ليس هنالك من
تبن رسمي واضح لما حصل في روستوف قبل ايام
او ما كان يحصل في بيل جرود او حتى في
استهدافه
موضوع النفط في سماره بالاضافه الى تطورات
البحر الاسود ولكن من الواضح ان العمليات
الخاصه هي تحتل ركنا اساسيا من المعادله
بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه عمليا على
مستوى البحر الاسود وما قالت موسكو بانه
محاوله من القوات الاوكرانيه لاستهد البحر
الاسود من خلال المسيرات المائيه يمكن
التجديد على ان القياده الاوكرانيه
العسكريه والسياسيه تنظر الى كل التطورات
في البحر الاسود من قبل البحريه الروسيه
بانها محاوله لفرض حصار كامل على كافه
الموانئ الاوكرانيه سواء ما يتواجد فيها
في
او حتى وصولا الى دلتا نهر الدانوب والتي
كانت تعوي الكياف على انه ربما من خلال
تلك الموانئ يمكن تصدير الحبوب بمعزل عن
الممر الامن الذي كان قد اقيم من اوديسا
ومن ميكولايف في وقت سابق بناء على
الاتفاقيه التصدير حبوب والتي خرجت منها
موسكو قبل اسبوعين وبالتالي الان تكثيف
وجهه الاستهداف الاوكراني
لاسطول البحر الاسود ياتي من خلال هذه
القراءه الاوكرانيه التي تعتبر بان موسكو
تحاول ان تفصل اوكرانيا عن كامل البحر
الذي يمكن من خلالها ان تصدر
حبوبها الى الخارج وبالتالي تعتبر بان هذه
المعركه لا تقل اهميه عن المعركه
الميدانيه المباشره التي تخوضها على طول
خط الجبهه وتحديدا هنا في المقاطعات
الشرقيه والتي تقول بعجاله بانها
القوات الاوكرانيه في باخمونط تحققوا
تقدما بينما تصد القوات الروسيه في مناطق
عده لاسيمه في كوبياس كليمان ومارينكا
بالاضافه الى ما تصفه القوات الاوكرانيه
بانه محاوله تقدم ضمن جابولوجيا ضمن
محورين اساسيين في ميريتوبل
شكرا جزيلا لك كمراسل الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم والشكر موصول ايضا لمراسله
الجزيره رانيا دريدي من موسكو